[Applause]
[Music]
in a time when we get to experience all
sorts of new and amazing stories it's
particularly exciting to see the unique
use of powers and the amazing characters
that use these powers in the worlds were
shown today we're gonna discuss the fire
users in anime not just any but the real
strong badass fire users we've come to
experience love and be fired up for a
bit corny maybe but bear with it please
also keep in mind these characters are
not ranked in terms of their strength
[Music]
we start a list off with none other than
the son of satan and hell's fire itself
rin okumura
from blue exorcist while in combat rin
surrounded by blue frames which scare
quite a few people as they burn through
anything and of course numerous deaths
being wielded by satan however
RINs able to effectively control his
flames to only burn what he desires
he's quite overpowered in his demon form
having super fast regeneration creating
bombs with his flames as well as
controlling the flames in any way and to
this his love of cooking what more could
you ask for seriously
[Music]
No
next on our list is Alibaba Saluja
from muggy he's really strong and
talented with the sword after being
trained from a young age after this his
use of the metal vessel possessing the
fire jinn Amon he's quite a formidable
opponent to face he's able to use the
weapon by burning his arms with Aman's
flames which enables it to take on the
form of a mole Saiga or the sword of
Imam Ali Baba is able to use a range of
impressive attacks from this form
including creating a vortex of flames
which incinerates anything it touches
and even a wall of flames to stop his
enemies from approaching
little bit
[Music]
moving on to number seven we have Natsu
dragged Neil from Fairy Tail
raised by the fire dragon igneel Natsu's
able to consume fire to replenish his
energy the heat of his fire is
proportional to his emotional state he's
a person that cares a lot for his
friends and will do anything in his
power to protect them he has a number of
attacks including Fire Dragons roar
where he releases a large amount of
flames from his mouth he's even able to
adapt amazingly well where he's able to
evolve and become stronger
he's quite flexible in his fighting
style and extremely explosive which
makes him a hard opponent to face off
against
[Music]
[Music]
this you kill me tie shakunetsu Nakata
he caca number six on our list is
Phaeton from hunter hunter he has a cold
personality that lacks any form of
empathy making him the perfect ruthless
killer that he is however the reason
he's included in this list is because of
the use of his nen ability known as pain
packer
he wears a heat proof robe that he
conjures from his aura to use disability
this is an amazing ability that allows
him to transform all the damage that's
been inflicted on him into burning heat
energy that's reflected back to the
enemy
[Music]
[Music]
get up man
number five on our list is ace from one
piece no list of fire users can go
without mentioning Luffy's elder brother
ace even as a child with Luffy claiming
that even with his rubber devil fruit
powers he was never able to defeat ace
so you can imagine how powered up he
became after eating the flame flame
fruit after which he literally became
the element of fire true to his name
fire fist ace his main attack is
launching columns of fire by punching on
top of which he's able to use haki he
was an extremely strong character who
added weight to the white beard pirates
by being their second division commander
[Applause]
[Music]
Ksenia or secret next on a list of uses
is the fire demon he ate being a fire
demon he's quite resistant to extreme
heat and cold his fire based attacks
include channeling human world flames
into his fists to add an explosive power
to his punches or even using this to
shoot ranged attacks you can use demon
world fire to shape it into a dragon in
an attack that can reduce a demon's body
to ash further to which you can wield
the demons flames as a sword if this
wasn't enough
he's also implanted an artifact known as
du gard zai that enables him to have
psychic powers he's a powerful demon and
a strong ally to have when faced with a
horde of angry demon
[Music]
[Music]
at number three is the flame Alchemist
Roy Mustang from the series Full Metal
Alchemist Roy uses special gloves made
of pyro text that generate sparks the
gloves are drawn with a transmutation
circle that enables him to create flames
where he manipulates the gases in the
air his precise control over the AL
chemically enhanced flames so accurate
that he can boil the water in a person's
eyes and can also attack enemies amongst
a riot without hurting any alloys he's
also one of the smartest alchemists
around which allows him to stay two
steps ahead of his enemies and his
friends and his wholehearted dedication
to changing the world for the better
makes him a powerful force
[Music]
but surely cycling tour nothing
number two on the list we have the
commander of the goat 813 genryusai
yamamoto don't know how this old man
looks for you he's very experienced and
is a master swordsman with incredible
spiritual power endurance durability and
strength his weapon is one of the oldest
and most powerful zanpakuto in Soul
Society
this combined with yamamoto spiritual
pressure creates a fiery orator appear
around him due to both having a similar
elemental affinity to fire yamamoto
himself claimed that releasing his
bankai and his prolonged use could end
up destroying everything from his
opponent himself and soul society itself
talk about being an overpowered old man
huh
[Music]
pas de su bono he was in Illinois
and finally at number one we have the
Lyon sin of pride s Kunal from the seven
deadly sins s Kunal has a unique ability
that allows him to draw the magical
energy from the Sun itself which changes
his appearance drastically so from the
weak timid man were introduced to he
quickly changes into a huge hulking mass
of muscle yes pretty similar to the Hulk
we're not quite since he's still quite
sane I assure you but he does have a
personality filled with pride and
arrogance that's just too badass and
epic to watch he's quite overwhelming
when you actually see him fight his
personality switch that occurs from
night to day s Kunal is fun to watch and
cheer for as he goes from weakness to
complete arrogance shocking everyone in
the process
they've stopped
so who are your favorite fire users in
anime comment below and let us know
thanks for watching this video I hope
you enjoyed it please do subscribe and
like our videos if you did look forward
to more entertaining videos soon and
I'll see you next time on Vinny Tube
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]